two of the country's most famous
military units are under intense
scrutiny today over troubling incidents
on opposite sides of the world a human
smuggling investigation led to the mass
arrests of 16 Marines from the first
Marine Division yesterday at Camp
Pendleton in California two other
Marines were arrested and charged
earlier this month now the accusations
range from smuggling illegal immigrants
into the country to drug-related
offenses and in a separate case an
entire platoon of elite Navy SEALs was
sent home from Iraq over allegations of
sexual misconduct and drinking while
deployed Jamie yuccas is at Camp
Pendleton that's north of San Diego
Jamie what more do we know well this is
what we know right now Tony those 16
Marines are in the brig on the base and
authorities here say they've already
questioned eight additional Marines
Marines are known for their discipline
and dedication to country but in the
past month authorities here have
arrested 18 Marines from this base some
for allegedly helping ferry undocumented
immigrants into this country in exchange
for money
[Music]
Thursday's arrest of 16 Marines occurred
in dramatic fashion in front of their
own entire unit the release of this
information was really so we could be
completely transparent the Marines were
made to line up in morning formation
like this one the Marine Corps filmed
earlier at California's Camp Pendleton
they were then arrested for offenses
that range from human smuggling to drug
related activities all 16 suspects are
members of the oldest active duty marine
division headquartered here just 60
miles north of the Mexican border
none of the Marines were among the 66
hundred active duty and National Guard
troops assigned to bolster border patrol
at the southwestern border the Marines
say Thursday's arrests stem from an
earlier arrest of two more Camp
Pendleton Marines near the Mexican
border in early July the pair were
pulled over with three undocumented
immigrants in their back seat and
charged with human smuggling both have
pleaded not guilty according to
authorities the undocumented immigrant
said they agreed to pay the Marines
$8,000
the Marine said it was not their first
time doing this and Border Patrol
expanded the investigation which led to
Thursday's arrests if they are in fact
found guilty of those crimes then
they'll be held appropriately
accountable for that in a separate case
on the 4th of July
an entire platoon of 22 elite Navy SEALs
in Iraq allegedly held a drunken party
that not only violates regulations
against consuming alcohol in Iraq but
there have also been allegations of
sexual assault one question the whole
platoon from SEAL Team seven in Iraq
refused to speak with investigators when
their commander ordered them home on
Wednesday he said he quote lost
confidence in the team's ability to
accomplish the mission Vlad
alright Jamie thank you very much